huh
yeah okay guess greenlight is a little
bit creepy the doctor's wife so I've
been looking forward to this one this
was a big deal when it came up because
of course it's written by Neil Gaiman
who like you know it's Neil freakin
Gaiman or on an episode of Doctor Who so
it was a definitely a big deal at the
time and that immediately gave it a very
just high level of anticipation and it
met it it really did I enjoy the heck
out of this I like that it is
self-contained but I think you would be
hard-pressed to call it filler it feels
too significant it feels too insightful
so I think be classified as filler so
this has the doctor and Amy Rory first
of all getting someone to buy the little
box which is just great that's a cool
way to start and they end up on a
sentient trash ball Michael Sheen does
amazing work
voicing house that's terrific I love the
whole idea that it's this consciousness
that base that is you know just holding
this little asteroid II thing together
and he's you know got patchwork people
who serve Him and Idris who the
consciousness of the TARDIS gets poured
into it's funny she actually also
it's funny she also appeared on the
Sarah Jane Adventures but I didn't much
care for her in that I think it's it
just goes to show you what a decent
script and a strong directing hand will
get you out of an actor in different
circumstances but she's really good and
I like the waist but it actually from
you know funnily enough I didn't occur
to me before but she behaves not vastly
dissimilar from delirium from Neil
Gaiman's Sandman comic books um although
I would say slightly more coherent or at
least there's a reason for why she's a
bit out of sorts a her consciousness
isn't supposed to be in a body like that
and be she's doesn't experience time in
the same manner so you know she's hat
she has the end of conversations early a
few times and she has clearly had
experiences that the doctor hasn't yet
which even throws the doctor off which
is kind of cool Matt's a speaking of the
doctor Matt Smith does fantastic work
here he really gets to do a lot in
explore a lot of different facets of the
doctor here you know being light and
bubbly and excited at the possibility of
finding other Time Lords and you know
but also kind of melancholy about that
because you know of why they're not
around anymore and actually like side
note I really like that Amy you know has
her line but you told me what happened
to your people and you told me what you
did which was a conversation we have not
seen happen but I like that they cover
that to establish that the doctor who
had been very slow to dole out that
information in either the 9th or 10th
incarnations but here he's much more
open about that and I kind of like that
that gets established especially with
Amy he but he's still carrying the guilt
because it's great in that line where
Amy says you want to be forgiven he's
don't we all oh boy
that one that one hits home but he gets
to explore so much he gets to do that
anger yeah you know being flustered and
just overwhelmed you know the excitement
and and his eagerness that the idea of
building a TARDIS console his being
flirty with Idris
and with the TARDIS inside her gets to
do so much so many facets that he's just
ping-pong hanging around all these
different aspects of this version of the
doctor but it doesn't feel like whiplash
he just does it he does these hard jumps
and yet at the same time it's oddly
seamless it's really weird but man is it
fun to watch and like just the lines
that interest gets are so much fun you
know I like biting its kissing except
there's a winner
I mean that's that's fantastic and
amazing there's a lot of good lines and
also I kind of like what gets done with
Amy and Rory in this for multiple
reasons I like that the doctor lies to
them to get them back into the TARDIS
where he thinks they'll be safe because
you know the doctor lies isn't
necessarily a thing that applies to all
incarnations of the doctor but it
absolutely applies to this incarnation
of the doctor and I kind of like that
that gets reiterated a few times before
it becomes super relevant to some later
plots and stories I think it's it's good
to see it so seamlessly integrated into
a story like this and of course you know
well-meaning he he wants them gone for
their own safety but he also knows Amy
and she won't go if he just asks so that
works really well
and as far as Amy and Rory goes you know
their chemistry together is still
terrific normally at this point I'd be
calling out ill and they fake killed
Rory again except that this time it's
much more about what Amy sees or what
she thinks she sees happening to him and
how and the guilt she feels about that
so yeah Rory dies but it's not about oh
my god Rory dies it's what like oh my
god when he's the oh man and he's so
angry it's like you did it to me again
you left me again and she is so sad and
he gets behind those doors again and and
also like it doesn't it doesn't string
it along like oh he's
it doesn't even really play like we're
ever expected to believe that we're here
to see Amy get put through the wringer
and that is played very very well like
that Michael seen my machine does a
stunningly great job making an
intimidating fun villain out of just a
voice and a green light that is all
there is to house there is nothing more
of substance going on with him than a
than a voice and green lighting yet he
feels like a real presence he feels like
a real tangible presence actually
overall there is the it's surprisingly
kind of low-tech and low-key this
episode there's still like stuff that
went into it they obviously they built
sets there is some cool special effects
especially with the you know TARDIS
console room in isolation chasing after
the TARDIS there's some cool effects
there but by and large it's not a
particularly showy episode its TARDIS
corridors it's a junkyard it the villain
is just a green light it feels more
low-tech yet it all plays because it
doesn't feel like it's confined by a
lack of budget yet at the same time you
know it's not just throwing money at it
to you know throwing money up on the
screen there's something kind of oddly
appealing to me about this thing
basically trusting in the strength of
the script and the story and the
performances and not needing to get
flashy or have house designed actually
as a monster or we ever see or what he
really looks like how whatever that even
would mean for him I and I like that I'm
just I mean I am always impressed by
this episode on every level it's fun
it's touching
it's insightful to the characters it's
got funny great lines it has sweet
moments it has intense moments it just
goes through all this stuff so
seamlessly from a writing perspective
but then it's also really well shot and
everything that looks great in its moody
is atmospheric it was a really fun
seeing the
previous TARDIS console get brought back
just for a little bit just for this one
so basically you know console room cameo
which is cool and I enjoy that it's not
important but I do kind of like that the
doctor acknowledges that's another I
couldn't save even though like he was
never gonna save nephew nephew was
completely under the control of house he
was an arm of this entity so like yeah
I'm not sure there was anything left to
save he'd probably been emptied out much
like Idris had but at the same time like
I like that little acknowledgment the
doctor is a really bad track record in
helping the OOD and just a little
acknowledgment of that kind of nice
there's so many a little touch of so
many little things and it all contained
in this fun bouncy episode that is like
that one wants to be but then it can
slow down and be moody and brooding and
you know look at the emotional
consequences of things going on to the
characters this is such a jumble of
tones and feels and just and so many
things going on that you it shouldn't
work this should be a patchwork mess
much like the people living on house are
but it's not I'm not entirely sure how
it's not but I really like this one the
doctor's wife
Yuri watched it lately what did you
think about it whatever your thoughts
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it other stuff down
there as well such as the link to my
patreon that would be super helpful and
much appreciated failing that or even if
you do that you can also like subscribe
share this video that helps me out as
well other links down there besides
click on stuff it'll take you places or
don't you don't have to because at the
end of the day you're the council I'm
just running the meetings so until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]